[Music]
welcome back Julian podcast this episode
is brought to you by Squarespace
15 about building a website do it with
Squarespace they have all the tools you
need to build a fantastic website and
it's very easy 24/7 customer support so
whether it's a hobby or a business or
whatever you want a website for do the
Squarespace by going to Squarespace comm
slash Jenna Julian for 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
that squarespace.com / - no Julian Wow
Julian is a poopyhead
are you insulting me in multiple
languages speaking of Julian guys I'm
gonna start talking because I'm Julian
Valentine's Day is coming up and you
know the best gift for Valentine's Day
is some me undies so it's better that
you just get ahead of the game you know
just get on top of it now me Indies has
amazing prints they always come out with
some sweet sexy Valentine's print they
have some existing Valentine's prints
for his and hers or his in his or hers
and hers and you can get a wonderful
gift for a very affordable price and
with 15% off when you go to me undies
dot-com / Jen and Julian and you know
what they are more expensive than your
average underwear but they are so worth
it they like I have not thrown out a
pair of Mandy's they last and they feel
great so check it out we're going to
Mandy's comms last Jenna Julian 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you buy them
you're not happy they'll refund you
that's it thank you sponsors Julian what
the hell is going on what is that it's a
dog pile okay well looks like this
episode started off just a little bit
differently than every other episode
ever tug
it's so cute how can you not like this
dog pile well is that a rhetorical
question well there on Kermit cries 24
hours a day
Kermit cries the exact amount of hours
that Squarespace is there for customer
support 24 hours a day
middle-of-the-night
wakes up crying anyway it is a gloomy
rainy day and we are here podcasting
once again but we have we wanted to do
something that we kind of [ __ ] up my
Oh a while ago right you guys like
wouldn't stop requesting like those
Wired interviews where they do you know
Jennifer Lopez answers the web's most
searched questions so we did a podcast
because everyone was requesting it where
we literally just answered like a would
top 100 most searched googled questions
but the worst part about it is we didn't
even do it wrong right like we didn't
even answer it we looked up like a good
list of like the top Google questions
and we did that list but we didn't
actually like search know we [ __ ] up
while we [ __ ] up and everyone was so
mad at us I'm like oh sorry family [ __ ]
how do you remember the name of that
podcast it's something like that
answering the most googled questions but
anyway the point is you guys wanted us
to Google ourselves and to look up all
the the autofill searches about our
names right mhm so buckle up cuz brittle
I'm double buckled don't double buckle I
have one of those buckles that goes over
your head in the shape of an X I'm
strapped [ __ ] like a car seat yes are
you in a car seat right now for big
girls okay yeah oh by the way car Z's
are not easy to put into a car holy crap
yeah my niece was here yeah I don't like
sort of learn how to do that is like
very intense it's like put all your
weight on it and then you thread it
through and you tight
down so so there's that that you guys
probably already knew that many of you
guys our parents or babies welcome
babies so we're gonna attempt here to
screen record and okay let's get rid of
this here
I don't need that well you don't need
Julian is a poopy no you don't read my
desktop no I do it just asked what was
this you know what it's wrong no I'll
give you one guess I don't know one
guess I don't know it's a TV show one
guess I just said I don't know you don't
know that's the point of guessing I know
you're doing this game really it's
ringing bad that's you'll owe ya come on
what are we doing we're looking at you
what if the screen recorder doesn't work
and now we've spent so much time just
talking about what your desktop and they
can okay well let me just paint a
picture for those who can't see it since
it failed in in the reality that this
didn't work it's Huell laying on top of
em five or ten million dollars in cash
in a storage unit not picture it is bill
burr okay alright you want to just get
into it let's start with you alright
alright so you gotta do things like does
jennamarbles okay ready yeah should we
do it on the main Google page like right
here Google does this have tattoos yeah
I have two tattoos I don't know I think
she thinks she has perfect pitch does
jennamarbles have mercy no I have
perfect pitch no I don't have perfect
pitch
give me a note and I will say it right
now I don't but I don't know how to
judge this c-plus
not a no murder no d-minor I don't I'm
not sure
d arbitrary there's no way
for sure I wish you had like a pitch is
there an app for that probably pull one
up okay pitch meter yeah okay hold on
keep keep making noise okay but to
answer the first one yes I have two
tattoos they're on both of my wrists one
is in very light pink ink that says I
have a 99 okay then don't get it that
has my mom and brothers initials cuz
they're the same and then on my other
wrists
we went with Kris and Shan and Jeff to
go get walk-in tattoos
we did friendship walk in tattoo day it
was very intense and I said can I please
have a tiny brontosaurus and her name is
chef Jennifer ne and she's green she is
in green ink I wouldn't say she's the
highest of quality of data well she's
also not exactly what you asked for
which is a little annoying but totally I
said I want a little green
she's much bigger all right do what is
that a clarinet doesn't matter some deep
okay you got to give me another note
Missy
[Music]
[Laughter]
perfect fit it's not perfect fish give
me another one II king of Chucky it's
the same that I just [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god
sorry
alright I'll eat no I don't have perfect
pitch right no but see you just played E
so I could figure out F so do that what
that's why you can't do it that way I
see back to see
[Music]
perfect but you can't you can't like
play a note in the nest or another one
because in theory you could figure it
out when we come back to that okay no I
don't have her let's talk about this
merch where is your merger why not my
merch is soul curse like on the surface
I'm just I'm sure to all of you and I
get asked all the time because I totally
get it some people would just like you
know they would like something I want
some Jenna merch yeah I just don't I've
worked with different you know designers
different companies and a lot of them
have been really nice some of them not
so much like for example I worked with a
merch company and they sent through some
preliminary designs and I was like super
pumped about them and so we went to go
you know put them up for sale and you
know like show people the designs and
then I got a bunch I got flooded with
message from this artist that was like
that merch company ripped off my drawing
department that's my artwork and I was
like oh my god we have to shut this down
like we tried to figure out a way to
maybe like buy it off of her or you know
do something like that so that we could
work with her but at the end of the day
we just like scrapped it because I was
like you know what though like I don't I
don't want to work with a company that
told me that this was their original
designs when they ripped off an
independent artist like on what [ __ ]
planet is that okay yeah at that point
it's not even about like making it right
with the artist it's like why would I
even go into business with exactly so
and I really betrayed my trust and I was
furious and you know they and that's
just one of like many bad merchants
expert yeah that's just one example so
we always like to joke that like my
merch is completely cursed I can't no I
couldn't sell merch if I wanted to maybe
some day I just saw Never Say Never
yeah it's not that I'm like deliberately
ignoring people that are like hey I'd
like to just have like a t-shirt or
something I'm not trying to ignore you
I'm like you'd be surprised at how
freaking difficult it is to just get a
company to produce t-shirt it's very
simple Mercs like not that we're not
trying to reinvent the wheel here but
very simple merch with like original
cool designs have them priced fairly
haven't shipped for a decent price and
it's just hard it's very difficult
totally and I
really don't want people in the comments
to be like oh my god use teespring oh my
god use this like it please yeah I
promise you we've tried a lot of stuff
and a lot of it for me has just been
really frustrating and not fun
so hopefully someday in the right
capacity and until then no I don't have
any merch I'm super sorry and I'm just
soured from the entire experience after
years and years of years yeah I do have
Jed of Julian merch but not the same I
want some Jenna merch does jenna Marbles
stream yes where's Gemma stream chat
where's Gemma oh we have a stream we
have jenna julienne on Twitch yeah we
answer the question oh I was just moving
on yeah we stream on Twitch pretty often
we game a lot I'd say we stream between
like 20 and 30 hours a week usually yeah
that's I think that's accurate on some
crazy weeks we get above 30 but it's not
on and we recently listened we for a
long time we agreed you know we kind of
figured out the best way to stream was
like me on camera and Jen off to the
side so you can hear her not see her but
we've recently installed jenna cam and
we've been experimenting with it and we
have a lot of things that we're gonna do
on the back end to make it possible to
where we can both like have stream time
you know because even with Jenna cam
like she can't directly just talk to
chat either so yes we'll figure it out
though does Jenna Marbles have a sister
she's a brother who's very tall but she
said no she said Jenna [ __ ] you she said
Jenna have siblings that's redundant yes
she has one brother the Royals have a
basketball game tomorrow yes
because they seriously want to know
you've said it enough times that they're
like wait a minute where's her that
makes me feel bad that the third
question for does jennamarbles is have
merch
that makes me feel really about yeah I'm
sorry y'all well maybe someday alright
so that should I do does Julian yeah so
lemme though oh they're also let me know
does Julian sulamita happen I have ADHD
not diagnosed per se but I think I might
have a little bit no I like maybe a TD
but you do not have ADHD yeah maybe a TD
I've actually been told by people who
can say that sort of thing that I have
not like diagnoseable levels of a DD but
I do have like a little bit of it yeah
well I mean I think everybody has a
little bit trouble concentrating and
things like that but you you definitely
don't have ADHD and you definitely it's
not to the point where it would
interfere with your ability to work or
do things yeah yeah Wow does Julian told
me to smoke no follow I smoke weed I
don't smoke or I smoke weed I don't do
any of that but nor do i vape well I
have vaped but I don't babe does Julian
tell me to vapor no does Julian's that's
Julian's let me to have a job
no so let me know if you guys find
anything know if you hear anything good
I have a job I have had a job making
videos for a while but now it's a
million different things that I do on
top of just like YouTube videos so yes I
have a job before the internet I had a
job as well I worked at a radio station
and I bar attended and yeah so I do have
a job
why is he he's been having a space
square space come on those Julian's for
me to have celiac I do have celiac
disease
I am gluten is my kryptonite I will not
be able to have gluten ever does Julian
told me to have a tattoo no I have like
eight how many do I have one two three
I've I have seven tattoos soon to be
eight seven tattoos shall I get naked
and show everyone
yes no does Julian Silas told me to
speak Spanish yo soy espanol si me gusta
el pabre when I first met you and I
heard your last name I thought you were
Hispanic like so Lomita I didn't really
I did not think that that was an Italian
last name yeah I think so yeah Maya I'm
not Spanish I do speak Spanish perfectly
but I'm not Spanish my my heritage is
Italian my last name is Italian but yeah
I think more people think I'm Spanish
than Italian hmm also I'm excited to do
is Julian because I think people don't
really know what I am Julian can we go
and do that next
sure let's do is Julian my last name is
French is Julian is Julian selling me to
bisexual hell yeah oh that's what people
really be looking for though deulim I'm
gonna do some are you trying to steal
Batman this is a muted bisexual I'm not
bisexual I don't know where that
question would have come from but yeah
people just wanna know okay there's
nothing I did that like well maybe we
were talking about doesn't you wanna
know if if they got it if they got a
chance well you're talking about this in
check well I'm with you so they don't
have a chance but I don't care sometimes
they in their fantasy I get it yeah we
were talking in chat about this this
what gave us the idea of podcasts
whatever but
Oh someone was like hey you gotta chill
with saying ladies can you tell me where
the men are and this search won't appear
as juniors how many Jewish I am Jewish
yes my mom is Jewish therefore I am
Jewish although I wasn't really raised
religiously we lit the candles for
Hanukkah celebrated Russia Shana went to
Temple handful of times in my childhood
but nothing crazy I was not bar
Mitzvahed damn I did not get to a bit of
money as a child I wonder how hard that
would be
I mean well I mean what cuz you have to
go to Sunday School and you have to
learn a lot of stuff like I wonder if
there's a way to expedite all that and
make a video no probably not
expedite it but they probably let you do
it you just get my mitts for that as an
adult just have you in breath there let
me know I don't I don't know why I just
said that I don't know anything about if
they'll let you do it well we should
look into it I think they definitely let
you study as an adult to you know read
all this stuff that you're supposed to
read it cuz you know your Torah passage
or whatever it is that you read Torah
portion yeah like I'm sure that a rabbi
would let you go is a good sheet no okay
I could write the notes on the inside of
my glasses or the backside of my water
bottle we play in the Maccabi Games or
the Maccabi Games that is so in upstate
New York like all my friends were Jewish
I lived in a really Jewish town and
there was something called the Maccabi
Games of the Maccabi Games which is like
a Jewish Jewish Olympics basically for
student athletes of high school age and
yeah the JCC Maccabi Youth Games is an
Olympic style event held annually for
Jewish teens between the 18 the games
were first held in 1982 in Memphis
Tennessee with a sponsorship of the
Memphis Jewish Community Center more
than 120,000 athletes have participated
world like wow I didn't even know
anything yet so like the Maccabi Games
would come and a lot of my friends would
be like host family so like kids from
all over the country would come travel
for the games mm-hmm and so you would
host these like student athletes so
super cool like my best friend used to
have like just
they're like it's like a foreign
exchange program but from kids in the
United States that were Jewish that were
just here to play basketball yeah I mean
like it was [ __ ] dope yeah and so all
of my friends like I was an athlete all
of my friends were always playing in in
the Maccabi Games and I was like I just
want to [ __ ] play you could know if
you were gonna do it bad not Jewish
what's up you you needed even a Jewish
stepmother in order to so they'll accept
like something very small as long as
it's something substantial yeah but you
didn't have that you couldn't do like
hire a stepmom for a day to take you
down there and sign you up no couldn't
do it I always felt a higher bottom off
Craigslist so left out looking for a
Jewish mom to sign me up for Maccabi so
left I'm like the Danny Almonte of the
Maccabi Games
that's very get that reference he was
that like 15 year old that played in the
Little League destroying everyone really
equivalent of like a hundred like
there's no way this kid's legit and
they're like you guys legit he's legit
you know an article like a week later
it's like yeah um the Benchwarmers do
you watch the Benchwarmers the the you
watched the movie the Benchwarmers did
you I don't know no no they made a joke
about that where they were like had this
full grown ass dude and he was like
Daniel monty was like a foot taller than
all yeah will you look him up we Google
him now we're just googling no with an A
I think that's what's his name yeah
Danny Almonte literally look at how
[ __ ] tall remember this dude look as
a kid this was your nightmare this guy
pitch I know you're like 11 and he has
his license 99 miles an hour oh my god
dude yeah and he just like wiped those
bull yeah of course he did how did he
not okay all right back to interesting
anyways we were talking about how Julian
is Jewish that you didn't have a Bar
Mitzvah and
I was jealous that I didn't get to play
in the Maccabi Games well oh so Maccabi
wait how old they all all my friends
also went on to hunt for Maccabi on
birth right and they were all just like
yeah I had a lot of friends get
birthright trip too I was always jealous
of that all I got is this rosary [ __ ]
yeah
but yeah I mean I I got a rosary and
y'all out here having fun teen Olympics
and literally an Olympic so in Israel
what the hell yeah there was every
weekend y'all got like a wedding style
[ __ ] party what the hell is going on
having been to more bar mitzvahs and
weddings yeah pretty much the same thing
and like say the same price tag it looks
like anyway soon as I meet a vegan yes
in two days it will be my two year vegan
versary January 15 thank you actually
tomorrow for you but yeah nice yes um
not by I'm not Hispanic
yes I'm Italian it's June so I mean
Italian I am is Julian Sami too and
Aires
I am an Aries
that last one said is Julian told me to
okay okay oh my god it's a video that's
funny
is Julian okay there's two videos oh my
god I'm okay guys guys I'm okay
speaking of okay Oh Julian this is the
most okay slash best gift you could get
for your significant other slash loved
one for the upcoming Valentine's Day
season look at these underwear dude
let's make a match look look what you
can do okay uh what kind of underwear do
you wear I wear women's right but you
know I mean I don't women but to excel
blue wears and then you select what your
blue wears women
Motul thong right and then it helps you
match up pairs so basically you can
select prints that you like these are
the adventurous these are the bold and
then these are the classic right all of
them are made of the micro modal fabric
which is three times softer than cotton
you get them literally shipped as a pair
so you have this one these are all the
bold ones why do I think the adventurous
I selected weird size you selected two
XL let's just go medium for both and see
what's what prints we can get but dude
me Andes Jenna how many me Andes have
you thrown out in the all the time that
you've been wearing these only the ones
that Carmen has gotten ahold of and
decided that we're his okay so I don't
have that experience because Kermit
doesn't sniff out my underwear like an
absolute creep also when you guys send a
sign up to me members you get exclusive
prints and you get deals on the
underwear themselves they also have bra
lets they have onesies that I am in love
with they have socks I mean they they
even have t-shirts I mean look at this
guy's hmm me Andes is the way to go
right now go to me undies comm slash gin
and Julian and you'll be treated to a
nice little extra discount on your
underwear and it's it's honestly a
really good idea for the Valentine's
gift because Valentine's is kind of a
weird thing right you don't know whether
to go crazy for it or to ignore it
altogether
also guys Squarespace is the website is
how you want to build your website let's
go to Squarespace comm squarespace.com
Squarespace helps you build a beautiful
website okay with the ease of use of
something that you never thought a
website being built would have it
there's no coding there's no there's no
really skills you need to learn to build
a website on Squarespace they kind of
have everything for you they have all
the templates here they have the popular
designs up top so you can see what
people use a lot then they have all
these different categories for you to
choose from so you want to build a
photography website right they have you
all sorts of example templates of other
photography websites and even like fake
ones to show you what it could look like
then you get going and while you're
building right while you're building
you're like okay I got this I got this
okay support I need to talk to someone
24/7 customer support you get a live
chat on the phone
it's an incredible service and it makes
building website really easy so check it
out by going to Squarespace comm squ ar
e SP AC comm slash Jenna Julian to get
10% of your first purchase of a website
or domain and you can also start a free
trial see how you like it but the link
is in the description to check out
Squarespace Thank You Squarespace
alright back to Google alright so now we
got to do is Jenna right Rob let's go to
college where'd you go to college you
want to type in Marbles cuz that says
Jenna Bush where do jenna Marbles go to
college and where did Jenna Marbles curl
up with the Suffolk University emboss
Sangeet and Boston University for
graduate school and I grew up in
Rochester New York
marbles dead oh my god no I was married
no I'm not married that was like a prank
years ago when people were just started
commenting on people that I'd say like
2013 or something
they just started claiming you were dead
commenting on people's videos alrighty
and stuff and then people would freak
out I remember that
I was like right when I first started
being exposed to like your videos in the
internet and I would look through the
comments and I remember seeing that
there was like a wave of it yeah it was
pretty weird because as soon as someone
sees it everyone's like oh my god what
happened and then someone will make
something up like oh it was a car
accident and then everyone's like oh my
god
as you know I was vegan you know Mom was
a Virgo yes I am beat is jenna Marbles
yes how was Marvel's in fireball why yes
was jenna Marbles in YouTube rewind 2017
that's really the top searched for was
jenna Marbles well you know I don't
think 1716 was the last year you were I
think so yeah weird fireball though
there's like you know not any more TL
Innisfil than people have already said
but yeah it's not an enjoyable
experience to be a part of that video
for the most part was jenna Marbles and
fireball yes I was can we watch that no
um it was really funny they had asked me
to do that
well Pitbull's people you know cuz like
Brittany Furlan was in it like you know
they're just it was a strategy to just
have people in your video to you know
boost your online viewership whatever
like yeah I'm aware totally yeah cool
yeah but it was funny because we really
liked that song like genuinely had
before thing to that song because that
was also a phase when we were drinking a
lot of fireball like the alcohol
cinnamon whiskey and I was like oh [ __ ]
like how am I supposed to say no to that
and one of the reasons why I would have
said no was because was it the day
before or that day we got peach yeah we
it was the I think the fireball video
was a Sunday
and I think we got peach like that week
she was like a tiny little baby yeah she
was she was at night and so I was like
is it okay if my boyfriend comes and
brings our brand-new puppy because we
don't like you know she's so sweet she's
an angel but she we didn't want to like
just get her and then leave her alone
with the other two dogs like you know
you kind of need some time to figure out
if they can get along with each other
when you're not there and like you know
just be safe so yeah we had asked them
like is it okay if we bring like our
brand-new puppy to set because we don't
want to leave her yet and they were like
yeah that's fine yeah you guys just she
was asleep the entire time like in a
blanket
oh she was such an angel she wasn't but
she was there for that shoot I'm trying
to find there was a video that we filmed
literally after the fireball shoot where
we came home and peach was sleeping and
she was so I think he passed it up oh
wait Kermit fills all the fields no oh
maybe not I don't know regardless
and she was like flopping over really is
it dead I was like you were still
wearing what you wore in the video so
yeah you're in fireball are you engaged
no are you a Virgo again were you a
go-go dancer yes that was a good answer
but it's not a stripper I don't it's
like people have never been to like a
nightclub where they see go-go dancers
it's like a foreign concept it's like a
big city thing you know and then I think
a lot of people that don't have those
big types of nightclubs with like you
know live entertainment which is like
people dancing up on a thing it's like
part of the experience you know you're
like dressed up and you know performer
exactly but you know a big big expensive
nightclub that charges you know twenty
five fifty dollars just cover charge to
get in though those are the kinds of
places that you'll see you know in a big
city maybe of like a live performer and
depending where you go like places in LA
they have people like doing actual like
aerial acrobatics
or you know just like a wild [ __ ] it's
just part of the entertainment but it's
not a stripper yeah
which still annoys me used to be a
stripper like literally never I'm so
sorry
nothing against strippers at all I just
wasn't one sorry yeah well I'd say good
point I never thought of that
the like the big city small city thing
because in like a really small town you
either have like a strip club or nothing
yeah you have like a bar or you have
like you know a place that might play
music and have a dance floor but it's
not a club
it's not up quote yeah it's not a place
where you would see somebody dancing
yeah you know yeah that's actually I've
never thought because you have to have a
budget for it in order to pay those
people a flat rate to be there you know
the club needs to take in a certain
amount of money yeah fair enough
what is Julian saw Mitas net worth I
don't know how am I supposed to know
that does anybody know their own net
worth I don't know oh I also just while
we were talking about it in order to
have go-go dancers your Clubhouse you
know how you need a liquor license oh
you need a license for they they need to
have like a live performer type of
license so not just any place can have
go go dancer because you can't just
decide one day that your bars gonna have
go-go dancers you need to go through
like the process of making sure it's
like legally okay right well because
we're performers so like if I slipped
and fell on something like your your
place would need to have insurance for
that type of so what I need to go
through the same like insurance to get
like a fire-breathing are you afraid
were you a fire-breathing yeah
fire-breathing go-go dancer but I
imagine it's really not cheap because
there were a couple places that I worked
out like the nightlife in Boston the
places that I would work out would sort
of you know with the exception of a
couple of really big places they would
turn over relatively fast like what the
it places are you know it can Los
Angeles it's sort of like the same
places that always kind of stay popular
I honestly don't know I'm very out of
the loop of nightlife well I mean some
of the places of you you know it have
existed for like ten years was the Abbey
yeah or like I'd
but like in Boston I felt like it was a
lot of turnover like the new it spot
would sort of like change around yeah so
it's very expensive to get that type of
license okay so like I know for a fact
that some of the places that I would
work at you know they were like you know
we don't have our performer license or
whatever anymore so you can't dancer
anyone got it interesting cuz it's
probably one of the first expenses to go
right well depending on how much it
brings in but yeah I don't know there
probably varies yeah what's Julien's on
me is zodiacs I what Joe zodiac sign
Aries what's your snapchat Julian
Sullivan I'm never posting on it anymore
what do I mean his job just internet
things what age I'm 26 years old
well ethnicity I'm white but I have
Italian roots what is a vlog oh that's
my okay what is wrong with Julian's
Alameda I don't know do you know there's
nothing wrong with you what is wrong I
don't know guys
you nasty he typed in Julian so lenita
just Julian so lemme know this Julian
Selena
what's Julian soul mate a spark the
drone I did I think oh yeah interesting
and then right after that it says Julian
so Lomita height which is constantly
debated on stream i even click on this
thumb you guys there's a lot of
misinformation on the internet about
that's not true I'm not five foot nine
why does why okay here's what I want to
know okay Google search priorites
prioritizes the most relevant uses the
most relevant and searched website hey
that's what though even search they
started a rumor that you were four nine
still for non on that website it just
didn't get it's not the default Google
search website all-star bio or something
I don't know but yeah you guys you
really enjoy
shorter than a mine I'm five foot ten
and a half five foot eleven on my
driver's license so just pump the brakes
sinner
yeah this is the I don't get that y
height line is the first I mean I get it
I don't have a wikipedia by myself you
know so like there's no Julian telling
me to wiki so to speak there's like a
YouTube wiki or whatever but I don't
have if I did I would like for that to
have my correct height and I would also
like for that to be the default search
on Google happy right now the internet
used to say I was like five nine which I
was like super pumped about like hell
yeah towering over beaches
jenna Marbles toothbrush oh so Jillian
just typed in the top results are aged
boyfriend networth dog murse so sorry
your toothbrush brother do you remember
the brother era where people said I was
your brother yeah that was another like
just case of wild misinformation it's
like one person you know really
adamantly responds that's her brother
everyone my brother
kind of weird this bizarre how that [ __ ]
happens dog
that's probably you Kermit is a popular
search oh wait what's your height mine's
always been correct on here it says 5 5
p.m. must be nice mm-hmm oh it's
probably cuz you have oh yeah it's the
Wikipedia so they don't do they don't
[ __ ] around
Wikipedia but Wikipedia didn't used to
have your age on it or your height sorry
rather really what you think
not usually no like if you look up I
don't know Barack Obama does it have his
height on there you know it's not like a
common thing I think it's just something
like boys have attire it I swear my life
it didn't used to be a thing where
someone's height was just not no I swear
I don't know but maybe huh maybe it just
wasn't like prioritized in terms of
information maybe it was there sometimes
but it just wasn't like
on every wiki in alright what's that
shirts now we'll jennamarbles
alright well it gave us is know how
about how does jennamarbles how does how
much this jennamarbles make how many
subs the general miles have how much
this gentleman was making money nunya
[ __ ] business
where does jenna Marbles why why does
jenna Marbles
where does jenna Marbles live where's
Jenna models work what is jenna Marbles
ranked on YouTube classified classified
somewhere why does jenna Marbles doglike
soap
why does ghetto Marvel's where need dude
why does jenna Marbles call Bobby oh
trying to figure out who I'm referring
to when I say Bobby to me that's marble
we call marbles Bobby well cuz they call
him like my bhole Baba like Bobby it's
just a little babble at him cuz he's so
little it was like that Twitter trend
where it was like your dog's actual name
and what you call them and where you
come why do you wear nude well for those
of you that don't know this was really
funny like when Sophie and I guard made
that video of like dressing Lee huge
yeah and she was like whatever I've
looked up neat dude I thought it was her
company that's not so me dude is our
friend Chris mall burger and John newbs
company and so we met Chris at playlist
tri-state however many years ago 45
years ago now long time ago and he just
like gave me a neat dude hat I'd like a
beanie the black one and I like really
[ __ ] liked it like it was just a good
beanie I just like that it's a neat dude
I would say was a superfan of vine and I
had seen lots of people wearing them so
I felt special you know yeah but it
started out as just the Hat which I
genuinely wore all the time and then you
know he became really great friends with
Chris and Chan and it was like he puts
out the walnut dude puts out merch
regularly and
it just I really genuinely like what
they make in there our friends so but no
it's not it's not my company it's not
during this company yeah although you
have put out a shirt with me dude yeah I
feel like at this point is one of my
only options to ever have a win with
merch
so help me Finn yeah I think like it was
so smart that the way Chris did it cuz
he was handing out those just very
simple neat ood beanies where it was
just said neat dude in a very simple
print but that became that sort of
they're sort of like you know their
thing and so you would see him pop up on
like line and YouTube but yeah it's
funny how like us wearing Neetu marked
the start of our friendship with them
too cuz that's like right we met them
when they gave you that yeah yeah I
really just wore it because I'm
genuinely liked it and I'm a person that
just wears all the same stuff all the
time
so we do this recur MIT yeah does Kermit
so after Kermit the Frog have teeth ooh
that's a really really great question I
don't know it's Kermit the Frog then
does Kermit have it alone okay good
question does Kermit excited why don't
you tell them what the results are
cause we're recording this well but
anyway I'm working my way down I just
searched it yeah so does Kermit like
only two of these or one of these is
regarding Kermit our dog but the one is
that does come and have Cushing's
disease yes he is Cushing's disease and
he's plagued by it every single day the
is Kermit the dog dead no he's alive
why does Kermit the dog cry I don't
[ __ ] know beats me we will look up
Sam it just Sam it is thermit sermon
what is service going to grow
oh that's the only one saerom it seemeth
dog breed Sam it inserts what that's
like an actual sermon it's a real thing
yeah it's like yeah people tweet that at
me onward sermon is a contraction of
ceramic and metal
assirram it consists of a ceramic
material such as titanium carbide or
titanium carbon nitride sir saerom it
cemented with a minnehonka seramins get
assertive salmon incentive as peach is
okay hold on is mr. marbles
how old is mr. marbles who is mr. Ramos
on Seinfeld it's a great episode I know
I finally like recently I finally
understood the origin of mr. Morales
name because we watched that episode on
the same time it's in season 8
it's the chicken episode Kenny Rogers
chicken roaster as the name of the
episode it's only in there for a brief
moment but it's a really good moment but
Jerry here's like little footsteps like
this around and he goes mr. marbles is a
ventriloquist doll by the way yeah and
Jerry pulls him out of a box Kramer's
like Oh mr. marbles he's harmless just
like this terrifying looking doll yeah
my old roommate named mr. marbles after
that all right so I just typed in my
name Julian saw me to height Julian
salomina pins Julian's on me to jenna
marbles tattoo Twitter shirtless no tell
me to high school
no also no you don't get to what
there's nothing what what I don't know
you're just like furiously typing and
then reading words what's happening I'm
reading the result that comes after my
name Julian Tomita so like I typed in my
name and these are pins birthday
jennamarbles tattoo why you saying no
what do you say notice well no -
shirtless why not we're not allowed to
see without you shirt on it so should I
click on it we're not allowed to be
curious all right there you go there you
go just let me go straight yeah I needed
a shirt okay so I've made videos
shirtless like yeah just want to see you
without you shirt on no I'm saying don't
be mad at them people in it me yelling
at room sick yeah there's plenty of
shirt list me out there I thought not
that much there's me in the hot tub with
you shirtless he cute um what was the
other one
James ah me too Oh high school high
school tweets no no no those are all
people that listen to the podcast
yeah you're looking for high school
sweet sweet we know you're here dog all
right let's friend jenna is what you
have to type in Linda's sentence I know
I'm trying it's like it's kind of hard
I'm trying to think where was Jenna my
name is Jenna I was born is Jenna you're
not dad no rich we already did all these
yeah no I mean jenna Marbles can these
be dunk please say dunk please say
Duncan can Jenna nope nothing little
jenna Marbles dunk you want me to search
that yes oh then it shows up
yep no absolutely not
okay Ken Julian yeah that's all does
it's all does and is about when did
jennamarbles get buried when did when
did you get married I did it I'm not
when did yeah when did is a good one
when does when does I can't type right
now when does in right nothing when does
Julian when is Julian's telling me to
birthday April 17th yeah I don't know I
mean I think we did a para bit of
googling of ourselves here is this
pretty tame yeah also a guy oh yeah I
don't know I've watched a couple videos
and people like really delve into some
of the stuff and I'm just like damn like
my first of all my stuff doesn't even
like pop up on those sort of questions
but then yeah also like no one really
cares about me doing interesting things
it's just like am I an Aries and how
tall am I I'm sorry sometimes people
just want to know if you're bisexual and
have your shirt off or not
you can't blame people no I can't hey
you know I'm curious too i Google things
too all the time but I hope I hope
googling that like helped he gave you
some entertainment I don't know right
yeah all I know is that we should tell
you an adult Bar Mitzvah I'm kind of
down we should look into that how do how
to throw a Bar Mitzvah why don't you
look up if you can have an adult Bar
Mitzvah are you looking up how to throw
a Bar Mitzvah
can you just do adult Bar and Bat
Mitzvah however many adult Jews who have
never had a prime minutes but choose to
have one later in life oh so it is a
thing yeah interesting maybe we should
do that well you have to like I don't
think you can just throw yourself a
party and
call it a Bar Mitzvah no you have to I
don't know you have to do there's
something you have to do though you have
to go learn and stuff yeah I don't know
how to read that it takes practice and
studying the newsletter join the
newsletter joining the new type in your
email and join the newsletter doing it
all right give me the option where did
it go here we go okay Julian what that
guy's got so much spam dude John at
aol.com spam well hopefully uh you guys
enjoyed watching us Google ourselves I
don't know what more we could have done
but I think that was a fair bit of like
looking into what's on the web about us
yeah did we miss anything not that I can
think of I mean it does sort of also
seem like unless you were looking for
something very specific like people it's
easier to find information by just like
looking at someone's pictures or videos
or something like that you know
then just googling it I don't know I
don't find myself like if I'm curious
about someone else
I don't really just like type into
Google oh you know we didn't do we
didn't like we didn't go on YouTube and
do searches is that a thing like people
searching for things maybe so let's so
does Julian sulamita
okay so these are all similar searches
smoke weed speak Spanish vape have a job
ADHD most though is this doing something
to buy Jewish yeah as well I mean
YouTube is owned by Google so maybe it's
Julian solo Meetup my favorite food is
all ramen let's see what pops up hey oh
it's someone's edit I'm gonna see it oh
it's just a clip
that's so funny dude play it again play
it again if you're listening to this in
the car or something it's literally my
meat holding up like all my Robin stuck
together so I hold it up on it onam one
chopstick Robin popsicles anyway
hopefully you guys enjoyed this thank
you for hanging out we will see you guys
next week right another podcast and have
a great week thank you sponsors and I'm
sorry that Google
[Music]